the new corona virus has already killed
hundreds of thousands of people across
the world
and it's happened our lives changing the
way we work
and who we can meet problem is we can't
see it
sars cove ii is an invisible deadly
threat
that could be lurking anywhere but not
everyone believes that
it's pure panic now i don't know anyone
who's sick
in march i knew sick people ski holiday
makers and others
we believe only scientists following the
guidelines of the government
are being listened to clearly many only
believe in what they can see
where does that leave us when an enemy
is invisible
[Music]
welcome to yokobit 19 special here on dw
news i'm monica jones and berlin
good to have you with us now for months
you have seen representations of the
coronavirus like
this one behind me but does the virus
really look
like this and does it matter yes it does
because
the better we know the virus the better
we can fight it and luckily there
are people who can make the invisible
visible
brothers ben and fionn had planned to be
with their grandparents in england right
now
the coronavirus pandemic made that
impossible
so what does the virus which is making
so many people frightened
actually look like um
it's got lots of like bumpy
things on it and it looks cheeky and
not very nice
yes it looks very cheeky
thomas bletchdusser a scientific
illustrator and animator
thinks the drawings are pretty good
though he finds many depictions of
viruses problematic
this for children's book is actually
quite nice it's a very simplified
depiction
which is totally okay but it shows the
main features and so on
but what i sometimes get a little bit
upset about is illustrations that are
used
for online articles for example like
this one
because they use depictions that do not
resemble the virus
at all and they are often taken from
stock image sites like this one as you
see all of these are supposed to be
coronavirus and each and every depiction
is completely different from one another
and none of them resemble the actual
virus
spletch duster knows exactly what the
virus looks like
researchers emailed their raw data to
him that includes information about
almost every atom in the protein
like the size and number of spikes on
the surface
he loads the data into a molecular
viewer and then exports it into his
state-of-the-art 3d software
which is also used by hollywood for
special effects
scientists use his illustrations for
their publications in popular and
scientific magazines
these graphic illustrations for the
scientific community are a valuable
resource
in the fight against the coronavirus
epidemic
the scientific data that they try to
show can often be very confusing
and hard to grasp for example here we
have the structure of the protease
in a molecular viewer and as we see it's
really hard
to see what is going on here the white
thing in the middle
is the inhibitor that can potentially
disable the whole potent so therefore
it's a good drug target
but it's kind of hard to see so what i
do is
i illustrate the same data
in a very clear way that makes it easy
to understand what exactly is going on
here in this binding pocket for example
this gives other virologists a precise
idea of what their colleagues are
working on
spletstresser is a doctor of biology
during his studies he was often
irritated by how many graphic
illustrators
had no clue what they were depicting he
decided to fill this gap
and so he became a scientific graphic
illustrator
he loves his job largely because of the
artistic freedom that exists
despite the rigors of science
here we have my illustration of the
corner virus and here we have the
illustration
of another scientific illustrator and as
you see we chose very different colors
and slightly different style of how to
depict them
even though the overall structure of the
virus are very similar
regardless of the colour ben and fion
aren't afraid of the virus
if they're able to see the invisible
virus they know how they'd react
i would tell him to go away and say
shoot push off
the two youngsters understand there
needs to be a vaccine against
coronavirus
before they can start playing here again
with all their friends
and before they can finally give their
grandparents in england a hug
for more i'm joined by professor ralph
hadwick director of the center for
adaptive rationality at the max planck
institute for human
development good to have you with us uh
please first of all you and your
colleagues uh you're looking into
cognitive tools and strategies that lead
to us being able to
to make a decision hopefully a good one
how important
is it for us to visualize something in
order to be able to act or react
good question uh i think i mean
if we talk about the risks and a lot of
our decisions are related to the risks
that we perceive in the world
one general finding in in research on
risk perception is that
things that we can see are actually
often perceived to be more risky
i mean just think for instance of
walking in a dark forest
and you hear a rustling and
of course it makes you afraid and that
feels very different than
walking through the same forest during
the day and suddenly seeing oh it's just
a rabbit
so things that we do not see tend to
make us more anxious
okay but that is very interesting
because obviously we've lived with this
invisible virus this new coronavirus now
for
for at least eight months and it seems
to be that this fear
is wearing off with some people they
don't necessarily keep uh distance
anymore they don't wear masks
anymore why is that
well i mean in all likelihood there are
many different
motives that come together uh um and you
can
think for instance of convenience i mean
some of these measures are really uh
quite inconvenient in particular during
hot
weather but that's certainly not the
only reason
there's probably also something in play
that is called
the prevention paradox meaning that uh
if the preventions were successful and
the catastrophe
if you will or the disaster doesn't
happen then one
question is well maybe the risk wasn't
that big to begin with
uh that is one possible reaction and the
other one is of course to say well
actually the prevention was successful
and i think some of this is now
happening
that some people seem to have the
impression that the risk is possibly not
as big as
it was often said in the media and by
politicians
but of course we all know that the virus
is still very much alive
and kicking so what is necessary
uh to revive the kind of fear or respect
that people had at the beginning of the
pandemic
well that's an important question and if
i could easily answer it i would
be much richer than him actually that's
a one million dollar question
uh and i think it has a lot to do with
the fact that we keep talking about this
as a crisis
and even the framing of a crisis
typically means that
a crisis passes um i mean a crisis is
typically
not years long and i think what's
important is that we
need to possibly change our mental model
of the problem
maybe that we need to adjust our
expectations that this is a problem that
is not going to disappear within days
weeks or months that it possibly stays
with us for quite a long time
i mean can we sort of learn something
perhaps also from
religion i mean every religion in the
world is based on people believing in
something they cannot see
they cannot touch yet they believe in it
they even follow rules
while others don't what is it that makes
the difference
in in people following religion and
something they can't see
and others don't
i have no idea uh but i i wouldn't
uh i wouldn't bet on the religion i
think that
what we are what is helpful is to
understand
to understand the data that we have and
and also uh to try to employ
evidence-based uh means in other words
uh there's now lots of evidence that
shows that wearing masks and keeping
distance is really an effective way of
dealing
uh with the corona virus and so i would
uh
for me i would not wage on a religion
here but really
on the best evidence that is currently
available
all right professor ralph hatwick
director of the center for adaptive
rationality at the max planck institute
for human development
uh thank you so much for your time
you're more than welcome well time for
your questions now
over to our science correspondent and
that's derek williams
[Music]
does sars cov2 incorporate genetic
material into your dna
that remains even when the disease is
passed
a number of of different viruses among
them for example
hiv or or herpes viruses
use a variety of different methods to
incorporate their own
genetic material into that of the cells
that they
invade in fact a substantial portion of
human dna
we think around eight percent isn't
strictly speaking
human in origin um it's genetic
information
from viruses that integrated into the
human genome at some point
in the far distant past and has been
hanging around
in our genetic code ever since which is
is kind of freaky when you think about
it i mean
it's thought that these sequences might
be involved actually in a wide range of
what we consider
to be non-infectious diseases like
like cancer or or dementia but sars co2
isn't the kind of virus that replicates
by integrating
into our genome it doesn't have to
invade the cell
nucleus where our dna is it can find
everything that it needs to make more of
itself
in what's what's called the cytoplasm
which is the the gel-like substance
that's
inside the cell membrane but outside the
cell nucleus
[Music]
and before we go a coronavirus vaccine
developed in russia has been registered
for use russian president vladimir putin
says the vaccine
offers lasting immunity and that medical
workers teachers and other risk
groups will be the first to be
inoculated
but many scientists are skeptical the
vaccine did not
undergo phase 3 trials which normally
last for months
and involve thousands of people